recording today we're gonna talk about  what it takes to be a coding monster I'm  a monster coder are you a monster coder  and no train driver  yeah he's monster coder here's what it  takes to be a monster coder  you got to get up at 6 a.m. every  morning he doesn't matter what time you  went to sleep you shouldn't be going to  bed before 4 a.m. anyway if you're going  to bed before 4 a.m. you're not coding  hard enough  so get back to the computer go stare at  that blue screen and just get back to  work right yeah right yeah ok and then  you get up at 6 a.m. you drink some  coffee  eat seven eggs and you take a big poo  and then you go back to your computer  but first before that you better go a  bit of a good workout you know you can't  be a monster code or without monster  guns cuz you go to type so hard on the  keyboard you're really really good